let's take everything away except our
picture of the prototype relationship
between these two objects and consider
this relationship just on its own if
this behavior was useful to us for
making the ROS object capable of
resembling the gold object are there
other objects in JavaScript that might
make use of this mechanism for example
does gold delegate its own failed
lookups somewhere in fact it does
there is a top-level object that every
JavaScript object eventually delegates
to this is where all the basic methods
are provided for all objects we call it
the object prototype because it provides
the shared properties of all objects in
the entire system that way when you ask
an object for its dot to string property
you get access to a function that can do
the appropriate work once you've
accessed the function you can
immediately call it and the object that
you did the property lookup on will
appear to the left of the dot at that
functions call time thanks to the way
that the parameter this works
the shared function will work as
expected with the this keyword bound to
the ros object even though the dot
tostring method was technically stored
way up on the object prototype